l'euro berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec
bien sûr comme chaque semaine
dailymotion est l' agence france presse
qui sera représenté dans un instant par
hervé hasquin avant que perrine tarneaud
de public sénat nous rejoigne il y
aurait donc une nouvelle loi sur le
travail le dimanche ce sera l'an
prochain après les municipales alors que
on va beaucoup évoqué les dimanches du
maire et qui seront plus nombreux 12
comme le recommande la commission ben
haim est donc le régime restera celui de
l'exception avec des droits garantis
pour les salariés est ce que vous êtes
en accord avec les règles qui ont été
énoncées par le premier ministre même si
elle reste encore confuse
pour l'instant moi je suis sur le
rapport ben ali le rapport bailly il a
deux avantages pour nous d'abord il dit
que le travail du dimanche est une
exception on doit rester une exception
c'est extrêmement important
c'est important pour les salariés
concernés c'est important pour le type
de société qu'on veut construire et puis
le deuxième point c'est que le
volontariat doit être le socle la base
c'est de ça aussi très important pour
nous que nous retard ya soit mesuré
soient évalués pour pas que ce soit
vitam aeternam
et pourquoi contraindre le travail le
travail qui participent au redressement
économique évidemment laurent berger
alors il ya des salariés qui veulent
bosser il ya des consommateurs qui
veulent consommer aussi d'abord des
salariés la cfdt a fait une enquête
auprès de 1800 salariés concernés
ça montre qu'à une grande majorité ils
n'ont pas envie de travailler le
dimanche et que lorsque il ya nécessité
il que ce soit la veille du volontariat
du volontariat du volontariat et avec
des contreparties importantes en terme
de salaire de récupération etc
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que la loi
maillé actuellement en cours est
complètement confuse personne n'y
comprend rien il n'y a pas du tout il
sait un maquis et donc les avantages
d'une loi c'est que ça permettrait de
dire quels secteurs peuvent ouvrir et
ensuite de laisser de l'espace au
dialogue social qui territoriales pour
déterminer les conditions de 2 contre
les contreparties pour les salariés
concernés
voilà donc des apports intéressants ya
des problèmes pour nous le premier c'est
12 il n'y a pas consensus autour de 12
dimanche les gens à auch d'humeur genève
les runs autorisation crois qu'on en
discute à 1 sur le principe de deux
électrons très important trop important
trop et puis vous vite combien c'est
trop 5 à 12 ans
il ya sûrement un juste milieu entre 5
et 12 voilà il a sûrement ajustements
mais c'est dans la concertation qui font
al fajr le mouvement dont une
concertation nationale sur le sujet et
puis l'autre poisse et les salariés des
petites entreprises de moins de onze là
il ya exception en termes de
contrepartie et ça c'est pas acceptable
pour nous on ne peut pas traiter
différemment des salariés des petites
entreprises de moins de onze que des
entreprises des salariés d'entreprises
de plus pour compléter vous accueille
voilà donc les deux réserves de la cfdt
sur le rapport bailly l'ouverture le
dimanche ne devient-il pas là demain tel
pas un impératif pour les magasins
aujourd'hui leur berger qui sont
concurrencés sur internet et 24 heures
sur 24 et en levant en ce moment par
exemple il ya la librairie chapitre qui
a de grosses difficultés il ya des
enseignes surcouf ou virgin qui
connaissent les mêmes difficultés
ces difficultés c'est aussi parfois
parce qu'on n'a pas anticipé un nouveau
mode de consommation et c'est pas parce
que vous ouvrirez tous les dimanches 24
24 que ce mode de consommation va
reculer
donc il ya un problème d'anticipation
dans un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
ont pas vu ce virage
et puis il faut le dire l'ouverture du
dimanche on pourra certainement saigne
ça fait pas un pouvoir d'achat plus
important pour les ménages pour les
citoyens et donc ce qu'ils écoutent sera
consommé une dimension on le voit dans
certaines zones où les où des magasins
ont renoncé finalement ouvrir dimanche
ce qui sera consommée le dimanche
et bien ne l'est pas l'autre jour et
enfin moi je le dis ça doit rester
exceptionnel parce que c'est pas anormal
que dans une société c'est même utile
que dans une société comme la nôtre il y
a un jour dans la semaine où on puisse
faire autre chose que de consommer et
c'est le dimanche le dimanche le jour du
seigneur jeu relativement rares le
dimanche est traditionnellement un jour
de replacer pas ça n'a rien à voir avec
des paris avec une région aux pointes et
une montée des comportements et des
revendications religieuses 1 dans
l'entreprise ça vous inquiète d'ailleurs
et vous vous défendez le dimanche bien
le dimanche chômé parce que c'est le
jour du seigneur non non pas du tout
vouloir vous faites fausse route en
revenant sur ses terres à la jeu
d'efforts
une exception de travail du dimanche
même s'il faut le dire 29 % des salariés
au cours d'une année ont travaillé à
dimanche parce qu'on oublie tous les
services publics etc
mais je défends ça simplement parce qu
on a besoin de temps d'arrêt alors il se
trouve que c'est le dimanche pour des
raisons historiques
peu importe lesquels mais je crois que
la société a besoin de temps en temps
d'arrêt de recul et de temps autre que
la coupe d'accord n'a rien en semble en
tous les cas vos deux réserves à les
deux réserves de la cfdt sur leurs
accords bailly la loi sans doute qui
verra le jour l'an prochain donc sur le
nombre de dimanches du maire et puis
également sur les contreparties acordées
aux salariés des petites entreprises
laurent berger est ce que la cfdt à
gagner de l'argent avec les procès qui
ont été intentés contre les enseignes
qui ouvrent illégalement dimanche non la
cfdt n'a pas gagné d'argent avec 16 ans
avec ses procédés et d'ailleurs je le
dis c'est procès là ils n'ont de sens en
tout cas combattent le travail du
dimanche n'a de sens que si on est nous
mêmes implantés dans les entreprises
je le dis fermement c'est à dire que
nous ce que nous demandons c'est les
contreparties lorsqu'il n'ya
contreparties négociées
il ya ouverture ça arrive dans un
certain nombre de secteurs où on le fait
le dernier et enfin un des derniers
étant la flaque aux cas la défense nous
avons signé un accord extrêmement
intéressant pour travailler avec nous il
n'y a pas d'accord n'a pas d'ouverture
c'est ça notre principe veut est
d'accord d'accord mais vu par exemple le
responsable de fo commerce alors connu
que ce syndicat sans syndicats avaient
gagné 7 millions d'euros grâce à ces
plaintes est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une démarche légitime
je trouve que ça pose problème ce n'est
pas l'objectif du syndicalisme de faire
de l'argent ceci étant que des
employeurs soient condamnés quand ils
respectent pas le droit
moi je suis syndicaliste évidemment
c'est normal mais après si quand ça
devient une recherche de financement
pour les orientations syndicales c'est
pas normal c'est le cas ba a priori 7
millions sera l'exemple
vous citez sa période où la pose
problème ce n'est pas une pratique de la
cfdt s'est passé le matin que je
souhaite que la cdt développe et le
développe pas et vous l'a condamné bas
puisque je développe pas en tout cas mon
talent avéré je la partage pas vous ne
partagez pas
le recul du chômage en octobre repose on
l'a vu un sur les emplois aidés
est ce que le gouvernement vous semble
en revanche privé de capacité de
réaction face aux plans sociaux
d'abord juste sur les emplois aidés
arrêtons de considérer que ces quantités
négligeables et que ça ne sert
finalement à rien c'est pour les
individus qui sont concernés notamment
les jeunes sur les emplois d'avenir
c'est extrêmement utile à condition
qu'ils aient formation accompagnement
vers un emploi durable
ensuite sur les plans sociaux il est
évident qu'il ya une responsabilité
forte qui incombent aux entreprises
concernées on peut les prendre les uns
après les autres si vous voulez alcatel
un registre
malheureusement il serait normal qu'un
tel un jeu de réelles difficultés
économiques mais le plan social qu'il
propose est trop rude et donc il faut
qu'ils réduisent la voilure en terme de
suppressions d'emplois et qu'il accepte
de discuter de ça avec les représentants
du personnel sinon on n'arrivera pas sur
la redoute ya une responsabilité
d'actionnaire très forte
il n'a pas anticipé et donc il doit
investi doit aider à l'investissement
pour course la poursuite de l'activité
et la poursuite de l'emploi des salariés
aujourd'hui même il ya des dirigeants
des cadres dirigeants de la redoute qui
se disent prêts à reprendre une
entreprise
c'est une solution qui pourrait avoir
votre côté notre équipe
l'équipe cfdt à la redoute dit qu'en
termes de conditions d'emploi dans cette
reprise
elles sont plus favorables donc il sera
trois tours ils sont en train de la
regarder il faut étudier toutes les
possibilités
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut sauver
au maximum l'emploi d'accord donc c'est
vrai que les syndicats jouent leur rôle
a appelé il ya eu le vote d'une loi la
loi florange sur la reprise des sites
rentables qui sont d'ailleurs plus tenir
du symbole à propos de florent j'ai une
question à vous poser est ce que votre
leader charismatique edouard martin va
s'engager sur une liste socialiste aux
européennes
j'en sais rien je n'en sais rien alors
qu ils n ont tout à fait hors ca rien ce
qui est sûr c'est que s'il le fait ce
sera une démarche individuelle
il se sera une démarche individuelle à
laquelle cfdt ne souscrira pas dans le
sens où elle sera individuel et il
abandonnera il abandonnera de facto tout
le monde un syndicat la cfdt
ce sont les règles il respectera edouard
verhaegue comme tout le monde les
respecte vous avez parlé avec lui il est
prévenu
il connaît les règles j'en ai parlé avec
lui mais je ne sais pas à ce jour à sept
minutes je ne sais pas quelle est sa
décision mais vous comprenez que
il fasse lui ou d'autres d'ailleurs le
grand saut dans la politique ça peut se
justifier mais c'est un parcours
possible c'est un parcours possible
qu'il appartient à chaque individu je
pense que c'est très différent
c'est très différent de faire du
syndicalisme il ya une dimension
collective extrêmement forte de faire de
la politique ou la dimension collective
est parfois un peu plus absente c'est
pas du tout le même
la même fonction que certains
choisissent cette voie moi je ne la
condamne pas à titre individuel mais je
n'ai pas là à la halle à partager je
suis extrêmement vous n'allez pas la
cautionner
non je pense que c'est extrêmement
important et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
que tous les syndicats et la cgt en
particulier soit cultivent leur
autonomie à l'égard du politique et donc
que les qu'il y ait des individus des
militants qu'ils fassent le passage
c'est leur responsabilité mais a dans ce
cadre après ils ne sont plus militants
ils sont plus militants de la cfdt très
bien voilà qui est clair ce qui n'est
pas clair pour l'instant c'est la
position des verts martin en tous les
cas on semble utile de parti socialiste
une décision personnelle lui à parfaire
la proposition il hésite quand je dis
plus militant ça veut dire plus adhérent
c'est pas incompatibles mais il ne
s'exprimera que la cfdt une bataille ils
hésitent peut-être pas écouter fort à
lui demandé j'aurais parlé avant alors
l'europe justement c'est là où on veut
mener maintenant le combat énorme apte à
la france accueille de plus en plus de
salariés détachés à +30 % un bond en
est ce que vous demandez d'ores et déjà
au gouvernement de prendre des mesures
fortes ou bien ce que vous croyez au
conseil des ministres du travail
européen qui va se réunir le 9 décembre
on dit que c'est le conseil de la
dernière chance d'abord la confédération
européenne des syndicats depuis
plusieurs années maintenant dès qu'il
faut revoir cette directive
là il ya une première démarche gang
enclenchée par le gouvernement français
dans le cas du conseil européen il faut
plus de contrôle et si l'europe
n'accepte pas des contrôles
moi je demande au gouvernement au niveau
national d'exercer lé contrôle et
contrôler ça veut dire regardez les
conditions d'emploi des salariés
détachés le même salaire les mêmes
conditions d'emploi mais regardez aussi
quelle est la responsabilité des
donneurs d'ordres collectivités
territoriales comprise quelles sont les
raisons qui font que des collectivités
territoriales des entreprises c'est à la
fois après la des salariés détachés et
regarder si c'est bien légal tout ça
ensuite il y a une vision de absolument
nécessaire de moyen terme qui est de
il faut le même une harmonisation
sociale en europe qui ferait que les
cotisations sociales soient les mêmes
d'un pays à un autre du même niveau ce
qui ferait il y aurait plus de sujets
travailleurs détachés mais c'est un
sujet très grave très grave très
important on parle de nos fichiers
encore d'un nouveau choc de
délocalisation c'est le patronat qu'ils
disent tous la même chose tous nos
équipes oui c'est un vrai un vrai
problème toutes nos équipes partout nous
allons nous le disent et donc il faut
absolument qu'il y ait plus de
régulation plus de contrôles et qu'on
revoie cette directive alors plus de
contrôles contre les abus les
contournements des règles du code du
travail
mais vous savez 4 l'attrait fiscal est
également des ces entreprises on entend
certains entrepreneurs dire mais je suis
obligé d'utiliser des salariés et agi
parce que le blu que je propose avec
personne ne le prend en france c'est
aussi une réalité
je crois que c'est beaucoup leurs
bâtiments cette usure c'est beaucoup sur
jouer c'est des salariés détachés parce
qu'on trouverait pas de salariés c'est
pas vrai nous on a plein d'exemples ici
ou là où des salariés seraient prêts à
faire le travail mais parce que le coût
du travail est moindre avec l'esa est
haché où l'on fait venir donc la
question et de ses ouailles on n'est pas
contre le fait qu'elle ait ça et à celle
qu'on nous entende bien il ya beaucoup
de français qui sont salariés des tâches
assurées glace et c'est pour ça on a
toujours une vision un peu au total 1
200 là mais faisons attention donc à des
discours comme le tien le front national
à faisant en jouant sur les peurs mais
en même temps il faut des règles il faut
des règles beaucoup plus claires et plus
de contrôle vainqueur un mot sur le
rapprochement entre la cfdt et la cgt
entre avec à vous parler comme est ce
que vous qualifiez aujourd'hui votre
relation avec série le pense et une
nouvelle entente cordiale nouveaux
signes apparents je pense et c'est du
dialogue du dialogue on a une conscience
de la période difficile dans laquelle
elle pays dans lesquels sont les
salariés il ya besoin de se parler pour
voir si on peut faire des propositions
communes déjà des propositions vont mal
et lors de nos parutions communes
éventuellement sur l'emploi la formation
et travaille avec jean claude mailly de
fo c'est quoi méfiance méfiance dont il
n'a pas donné sur une garde les sons
mais c'est pour l'instant un peu de
distance
fabien 60% des français estiment qu'avec
moins de fonctionnaires les services
publics serait tout aussi performant
dans notre pays est ce que c'est
également votre avis non je pense pas
mais je pense qu'il ya un an
plus de 70% des français qui doivent
penser qu'ils voudraient que leurs
enfants aillent à l'école des deux ans
et demi parce que c'est une condition de
la réussite
avoir de bons services de santé et puis
avoir des forces de sécurité lorsqu'il
ya des difficultés où il a besoin
donc le problème d'aujourd'hui c'est que
ce soit sur la force les services
publics où l'impôt est une espèce de
schizophrénie française qui considère
qu'il faudrait moins d'impôts moins deux
fois service public mais en même temps
plus de qualité alors justement possible
mais à condition qu'on en discute
justement vous voudrez celle engagée
contre le populisme et ceux qui
n'avancent aucune proposition allusion
aux bonnets de toutes couleurs mais leur
émoi au dialogue qu'à la contestation
dans un climat social d'exaspération
qu'il vous est difficile vous cfdt mais
également pour les autres syndicats de
canaliser avant d'accueillir hervé
hasquin de l' agence france-presse
sophie normand c'est un avertissement
toujours d'actualité dans une note
confidentielle datée du 25 octobre et
révélé par le figaro
les préfets alertent les pouvoirs
publics partout sur le territoire
peut-on lire les préfets dresse le même
constat d'une société en proie à la
crispation à l'exaspération et à la
colère la situation est explosive selon
le principal moteur de la contestation
la fiscalité les revendications elles de
plus en plus sont portés en dehors du
cadre syndical
les syndicats savent plus très bien où
ils habitent mais présente relativement
peu de monde qu'on a une cfdt qui
soutient beaucoup le gouvernement et on
voit bien que ça tangue parce qu'elle
sait plus très bien à quoi dire et puis
les autres syndicats qui disent non mais
qui ne mobilise pas
les appels à la mobilisation lancés par
les syndicats échoués qui ceux qui au
contraire marche c'est des mouvements
spontanés
ainsi des bonnets rouges voilà plus d'un
mois qui mobilise contre l'écotaxe un
ensemble disparate qui regroupe paysans
transporteurs routiers entrepreneurs
salariés bretons en dehors des partis
politiques et des appareils syndicaux
peu à peu la cgt la cfdt et finalement
fo se sont désolidarisés du mouvement
les bonnets rouges c'est pas notre
mouvement c'est un truc où il ya des
patrons il ya des partis politiques de
tous les bords
on n'est pas concerné par ça nous on
reste sur le rôle syndical qui est la
représentation des intérêts des salariés
que ce soit chez douchez gadoue dans
d'autres entreprises les syndicats
serait-il toutefois dépassée face à ces
mouvements sociaux contestataires d'un
genre nouveau
aucune crainte du côté de fo je ne juge
pas de ce qui se passe en ce moment en
disant avoir regardé ce sont je crois
moi les artisans les centres équestres
qui manifestent ou se dire que les
syndicats sont plus dans le coup ça
l'est mais ça veut dire qu'on a le nez
dans le guidon on fait un focus sur un
truc on oublie tout ce qui s'est passé
avant et on pense pas ce qui se passera
derrière aidé par jean marc ayrault
les organisations syndicales devraient
revenir sur le devant de la scène
médiatique
le premier ministre a lancé une
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux pour préparer une réforme
fiscale leur donnant par là l'occasion
de reprendre la main voilà avec nous
donc l agence france presse qui suit
l'elysée pour la fpf bon soir hervé vos
questions au secrétaire général de la
cfdt
eh bien rien entendre des syndicats
marginaliser les syndicats teaser à la
remorque du mouvement social est ce que
c'est un souci majeur pour vous
aujourd'hui
est-ce que 8 % de syndiqués en pleine
crise est-ce que c'est acceptable non
mais d'abord monsieur deuxième portant
fo les syndicats seront pas du tout à la
remorque ont marginalisé je suis
d'accord avec jean claude mailly
lorsqu'il dit mais attendez on regarde
un focus et au bout d'un an nous regarde
pas qui sont aux côtés des salariés
d'alcatel de la redoute de gad et et
s'est laissé les syndicats
les syndicats qui concrètement dans les
entreprises agissent qui sont aux côtés
des salariés qui travaillent le dimanche
et obtiennent des contreparties pour eux
les syndicats donc mois d'août je me
sens pas marginalisé par un mouvement
dont je partage les objectifs
et puis deuxième chose sur le nombre de
syndiqués 8%
c'est trop faible il faut faire plus je
suis d'accord mais lorsque j'entends
monsieur woerth dire qu'il ne présente
pas grand monde
je rappelle qu à elle toute seule la
cfdt huit cent cinquante mille adhérents
à plus d'adhérents que tous les partis
politiques confondus dans ce pays alors
si on veut s'amuser à ce petit joujou à
ce petit jeu de négation des corps
intermédiaires allons-y mais ça nous
emmène dans le mur donc attention
oui les syndicats ont des progrès à
faire je m'y attache tous les jours mais
ce petit côté cette petite musique
ambiante où les syndicats ne
représentera plus personne ne sera pas
utile et c'est très dangereux et c'est
pas la vérité poujadisme vous n'y êtes
pas allé un peu fort là sur les bugs
bonnet rouge
vous parlez de poujadiste pour les
bonnets rouges ah oui je crois que l'on
peut parler de poujadisme de certains
petits patrons ou agriculteurs qui ont
qui ont fait croire que le problème de
la bretagne et l écotaxe le problème des
entreprises agroalimentaires et l
écotaxe quand elle n'est pas encore en
oeuvre et qui dans le même temps il fut
demandé la suppression de l'écotaxe en
ayez pas à dissiper la production de
volailles de qualité qui leur a permis
d'avoir des entreprises performantes
réclament le maintien des aides
européennes pour produisent des produits
de produire produire des produits de
mauvaise qualité
c'est quand même très inquiétant car
vous dénoncez où jadis mais j'ai beau
nez rouge mais même leur corporatisme
c'est un reproche qu'on pourrait rester
aux syndicats quand même le corporatisme
défense des intérêts catégoriels non le
retrouver dès jeudi la cfdt
vous vous permettez que je ne parle
qu'au nom de la cfdt mais là vous avez
défendu l'ensemble du corps sans vie que
oui c'est vrai parce qu'il ya tous les
syndicats qui régulièrement son côté des
salariés lorsqu'ils ont des difficultés
nous on essaie j'ai régulièrement ses
quotidiennes au repos racisme ne pas que
le fait des bonnets rouges ça peut être
mais moi je dis qu'on réalisé sur les
bonnets rouges sur le problème et c'est
qu'à un moment donné il a ils ont été
présentés par les uns ou les autres
comme étant une espèce de mouvement
social qui aurait de l'avenir et c'est
d'abord quand on prend une référence qui
est forcément historique s'impose un
petit peu de difficulté on est en 2013
on n'est pas en 1600 et quelques et puis
il portait des intérêts très
contradictoires très contradictoires les
uns des autres alors un autre sujet
qu'il mène d'ailleurs
c'est le chômage vous dites que le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez sur le
chômage c'est ce qu'il faut en faire
plus c'est ce qui est un problème
françois hollande est ce que vous êtes
un déçu du hollandisme en eau loger pas
être déçu je voudrais c'est comme dans
l'entreprise quand je t'ai légumes du
personnel je faisais avec celui qui
était en phase donc aujourd'hui un
président qui est lui un gouvernement je
fais avec eux puis demain il peut y
avoir d'autres je serai avec d'autres
donc j'ai pas être déçus ou pas déçu moi
je suis concentré sur mes objectifs sur
les objectifs de la cfdt sur le chômage
oui on peut faire plus on peut faire
plus comment en accompagnement en
accompagnant davantage les salariés qui
sont au chômage qui le subissent
durement la bo de plus en plus demandeur
d'emploi longue durée donc il ya des
choses qui ont été faites sur les jeunes
il faut qu'on fasse plus sur les seniors
et demandeurs d'emploi longue durée et
puis par une politique de croissance qui
permettent de recréer de l'emploi
il se fait des choses et en termes de
politique industrielle avec les 34
projets en termes de compétitivité avec
les travaux de monsieur gallois mais on
sent pas encore le cap à osaka on ne
sent pas où on va en termes de modèle
des gangs par le temps le cap existe si
on en croit françois blanc grâce et la
compétitivité les entreprises c'est ça
la priorité du gouvernement donc 20
milliards d'allègements fiscaux pour les
entreprises et une hausse de la tva au
1er janvier c'est ça le 24 que dans le
cap
il y ait la compétitivité c'est pas un
gros mot pour la scène était oui il faut
une compétitivité des entreprises
mais dans le même temps il faut dire ce
qu'on veut faire au niveau social
c'est-à-dire le cap là il est clair
c'est le cas c'est la politique de
l'offre
non mais le cap et un bracelet qui suit
partners et roland pour la fp vous le
confirme à partir du moment où le met le
cap pour être comprise il y en a il faut
qu'il soit compris si dans ce cas
personne n'a rien on pourrait assumer
pour qu'il y ait un cap il faut qu'on
explique aux citoyens aux salariés que
d'accord il faut faire un certain nombre
d'efforts charge 3 tout le monde l'a
compris il faut se mobiliser
ok tout le monde l'a compris mais il
faut aussi dire où on va en termes de
cohésion sociale en termes d'emploi en
termes de vivre ensemble concret termes
de qualité de l'économie concrètement
lorsqu'un cas pas définir c'est celui de
la qualité contribue concrètement hausse
de tva au 1er janvier vous êtes pour
vous êtes contre nous on n'a jamais été
pour la hausse de la tva on pense que
c'est à la fois directe à justin rose
qu'il faut supprimer la hausse prévue le
1er janvier
et bien ça c'est une question d'autorité
vous savez un monde
non mais de qui on prend une décision à
un moment donné elle est légitime à
aller voter par le parlement
même si elle arrive en place un an après
elle est légitime et donc la hausse de
la tva
je le redis la sérénité n'est pas pour
la tva mais ceci étant au 1er janvier
c'est ce qui est prévu pour financer la
compétitivité qui le met en place mais
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir cette vraie mise
à plat fiscale que nous avons réclamé
presque tous vous convient dans ce
crédit impôt compétitivité emploi du
gouvernement les 20 milliards que
qu'évoquer hervé à l'instant est ce que
vous estimez qu'ils sont bien orientées
moi je pense qu'il mériterait même si ça
pose des difficultés techniques d'être
davantage orientée avec les secteurs qui
sont plus soumis à la complétude des
compétitions internationales et qu' il
n'y a pas assez de ciblage et donc vous
vous donner c'est de voir monter d'un
effet d'aubaine
je dénonce personne je dis juste des
entreprises qui déjà investis sont en
bonne santé et qu'ils vont bénéficier
dessus cice le problème c'est qu'il faut
qu'on discute dans ce cas de comment
elle aurait participé au prix en
direction des salariés parce que sinon
ça devient un vrai phénomène et la
grande remise à plat de la fiscalité
promise par heroes vous en attendez quoi
la mort moi j'en attends ce que
j'appelle la vérité des prix qui paye
quoi et pourquoi parce que le mal est
fiscal qui est grandissant le ras-le-bol
fiscale comme dit le ministre de
l'économie c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux parce que le consentement à la
pour recul et circulent faut qu'on dise
à quoi ça sert de payer impôts donc faut
qu'on parle des recettes et des dépenses
est ensuite faut qu'on se demande qui
paye quoi qu'est-ce qui doit reposer sur
la fiscalité des ménages
qu'est-ce qui doit reposer sur la
fiscalité des entreprises du patrimoine
du capital et puis il faut que ce soit
l'impôt sur le revenu qui soit le socle
le sol
aujourd'hui ce que qui est perçu par
l'impôt sur le revenu est plus faible
que ce qui est perçu par les impôts
indirects tva et c'est donc tout le
monde souhaite refaire le socle d'un
avenir a lancé sur deux ne payent pas
l'impôt sur le revenu soit c'est une
situation volume et or est ce à dire que
vous pouvez en faire ma soeur si vous
voulez en faire les gars il faut l'aimer
de michel jean personnellement paye je
pense que il n'est pas anormal selon les
moyens que chacun paye ça peut être
extrêmement modeste mais ceci étant à
condition qu'on ne paye pas par ce biais
là et que deux en même temps on paye par
le biais de la tva parce que est ce que
vous savez que les impôts indirects pèse
évidemment davantage sur les ménages est
plus faible les à plus faible revenu
parce que leur part de d'impôt vision
parcellaire
direct et plus près ce que vous aimeriez
que tout le monde alors du coup paix il
la faut sur le revenu à condition
oui que ce soit le socle et que l'impôt
soit davantage à l'impôt sur le revenu
est pas un impôt sur le revenu pour une
partie minoritaire est majoritairement
sur des impôts indirects donc il faut
faire revenir sur leur vrai mandat sur
une fois un tournant dans la politique
fiscale il faut que le balancier repart
de leur côté que les classes moyennes
dont on dit qu'elles sont les plus
touchés par la politique ou du
gouvernement soit un peu épargné il faut
d'abord d'une mise à plat et et redonner
du sens moi je crois que plus personne
n'y comprend rien et quand on comprend
plus rien à lui qu'est ce que vous allez
vous comme moi je les dis je re veut je
veux que sur l'impôt sol c'est l'impôt
sur le revenu qui soit d'abord l'impôt
le plus important dans ce pays
le revenu c'est le travail mais c'est
aussi le capital c'est le patrimoine
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas c'est ça
l'intérêt ensuite nous voulons une
refonte du financement de la protection
sociale
nous voulons regarder ce qui doit
reposer sur le travail et ce qui doit
reposer sur l'ensemble des revenus
chacun et voilà déjà sûr d'aller sur ces
deux axes la en 2015 au travail en 2014
on travaille son financement de la
protection sociale et on avance sur ce
qu'on veut en termes d'impôts parce que
je crois pas une réforme fiscale haut
rhin en moi eh bien on aura déjà avancé
mais en donnant du sens et en faisant de
la pédagogie alors l'ump dit il faut
faire tout à fait autrement il faut
gouverner par ordonnances et là il ya
pas de propositions l'est notamment
on met fin à l'emploi à vie pour les
fonctionnaires 30 les dessins les
licenciements possibles c'est la vie
plus facile
introduire une forte créativité des
allocations chômage ac bruno le maire et
jean pierre raffarin qui est à votre
place il ya quelques semaines
lui disait qu'il fallait abaisser les
seuils d'effectifs dans les entreprises
pour alléger leurs contraintes
ça vous inquiète ça m'inquiète chose
surtout que c'est pas cohérent
c'est pas cohérent on peut la
dégressivité des allocations chômage au
moment où il ya trois millions de
chômeurs et où il n'y a pas d'emploi
killer coke il faut qu'ils puissent
trouver c'est d'abord ça fait un
problème de consommation
ce qu'il faut savoir que les personnes
qui bénéficient d'allocations chômage
ils consomment à peu près leur
allocation malheureusement parce que
c'est pas ce pas 13e salon à dire dans
un contexte extrêmement tendu où la
cohésion sociale est mise à mal
où il ya trois millions de plus trois
millions de chômeurs essayez de faire
porter la responsabilité de la situation
aux règles d'assurance chômage c'est
quand même gonflé essayez de dire que ce
sont les chômeurs parce que ils ont une
allocation qui veulent pas retrouvé du
travail c'est complètement stupide
donc on peut rénover un certain nombre
de choses on peut discuter des séries on
peut discuter un certain nombre de
sujets mais de considérer qu'il faudra
des mesures extrêmement brutal qui
toucherait les plus frappants 90
l'appartenance est extrêmement total
c'est dangereux est ce que vous dit
souhaiter à tous les ténors ump la
cuillère ordonnance je vais vous dire je
dis les gens dedans je pense que la
démocratie est en difficulté aujourd'hui
est que la démocratie c'est l'écouté des
citoyens et c'est faire en sorte que des
intérêts contradictoires se confrontent
positivement pour faire émerger les
compromis ça c'est la démocratie il faut
le préserver
parce que c'est c'est un espace trop
rare dans ce monde nous nous avons la
chance d'évoluer dans un espace
démocratique
préservons le et pour ça il faut des
corps intermédiaires il faut du dialogue
utile et après je mets réforme ils font
déjà n'empêche pas il faut des
politiques qui décident oui mais il faut
du dialogue il faut de la construction
commune et et et renoncer à sa de la
part de ceux qui d'ailleurs lorsqu'il
était au gouvernement était quand même
très content car moment donné on pas au
donne des idées on passe des compromis
compris avec le patronat je trouve que
c'est un peu le mensonge et est en tout
cas c'est dangereux en termes
démocratise un vieux vêtement mais
mettre fin au travail
à vie des fonctionnaires par exemple ça
vous fait réagir aussi mais oui mais
c'est je pense honnêtement que c'est un
faux sujet c'est encore une fois la
recherche de boucs émissaires
voilà nous avons du mal à poser le bon
diagnostic dans ce pays nous avons du
mal à faire émerger des compromis
positif
l'opposition le gouvernement à
difficultés pour trouver un cap mais
l'opposition n'a pas d'opposition c'est
à dire qu'il propose pas grand chose et
on essaye de dire voilà il c'est de la
faute à untel c'est de la faute aux
fonctionnaires d'un côté ça sera de la
faute aux travailleurs étrangers de
l'autre et c'est ben allons continuer
comme ça et on va dans le mur
vous dites c'est je fais avec celui qui
est là avec le pouvoir en place
donc c'est quand même plus facile avec
le ps qu'avec l'ump
et vous savez si vous invite à regarder
la période 2007 2009 il ya eu des
accords
il ya eu de la corse la position de la
corse le premier accord sur le marché du
travail va vous dire ça soit marché du
travail il ya eu l'accord soit là la
position commune sur la représentait pas
que ça local c'est parce que gilbert
l'activité celle ce jeudi c'était il ya
eu une période de dialogue social aussi
léger à dévier avec qui veut dialoguer
la cgt dit il voit pas la différence
entre sarkozysme et le hollande ici
c'est vous le voyez il ya en tout cas
par rapport à la dernière période de
nicolas sarkozy il ya une très une
méthode et je rappelle qu'il ya eu un
accord le 11 janvier sur le marché du
travail
donc tout le monde à passer par pertes
et profits ont l'impression qu'il existe
plus et un accord de moyen et long terme
il à produire des effets mais dans ce
pays on met 30 ans à se mettre d'accord
sur un certain nombre de sujets une fois
qu'on s'est mis d'accord avec quelques
controverses quand même eh bien on
voudrait qu'on six mois sa règle tous
nos fenêtres géant des réformes de fond
structurel la cdt y est prête elle l'a
montré à de multiples reprises
menant un dialogue il faut du temps
effectivement vous avez raison de
rappeler par exemple dans cet accord
peur pour l'emploi il y avait le
renchérissement des contrats courts 1
laurent berger qu'est ce qu'on voit là
des derniers chiffres montrent une
explosion des cdd de moins d'un mois
manifestement un ils sont plus coûteux
pour les entreprises mécènes les foules
les derniers chiffres ils sont soit des
dix dernières années le la majoration
elle est depuis juin
je vais moins d'un mois elle est due lp
oui mais la majoration à les filles
juillet et les derniers chiffres sur les
dix dernières après ça si ça continue
d'augmenter les contrats courent ça
voudra dire que la surcotisation est pas
suffisante
et puis ça voudra dire qu'on a bien fait
de l'état est surtaxé parce que moi ça
donne des ressources supplémentaires
l'assurance chômage
très bien merci
perrine tarneaud arrive maintenant on va
tenter de base de mieux vous connaître
leurs bergers puisque vous avez pris la
succession de laurent de françois
chérèque maintenant bien il ya un an
juste toujours tout juste voilà c'est
l'anniversaire est ce qu on va souffler
la bougie ensemble avec marie brémaud il
souffle sa première bougie à la tête de
la cfdt mais cela n'a rien d'un hasard
dans le syndicalisme semble inscrit dans
les gènes des bergers le père et la mère
étaient tous deux cédétiste le fils
laurent naturellement prend sa carte de
la cfdt en 1991 pour ne jamais quitter
la maison un an à peine
et le secrétaire général de 45 ans
semble avoir fait taire les mauvaises
langues qui ne voyaient en lui qu'un
apparatchiks
il a un langage simple se permettaient
les apparatchiks ont souvent des
langages un peu compliqué bon il n'a pas
un langage de langue de bois alors que
les apparatchiks dit on ont souvent un
langage de langue de bois il est simple
il est compréhensible
il sait ce qu'il veut dire et j'ai lu
dans un article récemment qu'un militant
avait dit aux journalistes qui reprenait
que en fait j'étais plus techno que lui
donc voilà ça y est maintenant c'est lui
qui est l'homme de terrain et moi je
suis devenu le techno salut ça doit le
faire rire lui
moi ça me fait sourire on le voit
rarement sourire laurent berger le
numéro un de la cfdt a la réputation
d'être un homme sérieux bosseur au franc
parler
moins flamboyant que son prédécesseur
avec qui on le compare encore
régulièrement son prédécesseur était un
homme plutôt dit rue en plus haut en
couleur apparemment plus chaleureux et
plus empathique laurent berger est plus
réservé maîtrise sans doute mieux son
propos pour le faire correspondre à sa
pensée dont en termes de style il est il
est en effet très différents mais la
comparaison n'affecte pas le lien qui
unit les deux hommes françois chérèque a
tout fait pour que la transition s'opère
en douceur moi je pense qu'il a raison
d'eux
de se protéger je pense qu'au début on a
toujours besoin de se protéger parce que
le choc est fort en a beau être prévenu
que c'est un poste difficile les
premiers mois sont les problèmes les
plus difficiles parce qu'il ya
l'exposition médiatique forte et puis
aussi la tente des militants dans une
situation sociale complexe et qui est
très forte aussi si laurent berger
cultive la discrétion personnel il a la
lourde tâche de maintenir son syndicat
dans la lumière
voilà ce soir depuis une demi heure
maintenant alors engagé avec perrine
tarneaud question de steam alors
maintenant question de style chez payot
va nous dire laurent vergès avec raymond
soubie et françois chérèque sont plutôt
agréables avec vous dans ce reportage
voix qui m'a souvent reproché finalement
d'être un apparatchik d'avoir fait toute
votre carrière dans les différents
échelons la cmdt
oui c'est pas tout à fait vrai
d'ailleurs mais j'ai pas envie de me
justifier mes tout à fait les fonctions
plus alors donc parce que on voudrait
des responsables syndicaux qui soit plus
jeunes mais on voudrait qu'ils aient
fait le parcours de gens qui arrivent en
responsabilité à 50 ou 55 ans j'ai
travaillé mais ça considère on considère
aussi que un syndicaliste il n'a pas été
dans les secteurs industriels s'est pas
vraiment syndicaliste moi j'ai exercé
deux mandats délégués du personnel dans
une petite entreprise de moins de onze
south et un autre style le syndicalisme
il existe j'ai connu le chômage ce qui
n'est pas le cas de tous les leaders
syndicaux ce n'est pas une fierté mais
c'est une réalité
moi je suis d'une génération qui a subi
beaucoup plus de précarité que d'autres
voilà donc et je crois que j'ai commencé
à l'union locale de saint nazaire sur le
terrain des petites entreprises a
affirmé m émerger des sections
syndicales donc voilà je vous disais
militants quand je vais les rencontrer
pour vous protéger comme vous a
conseillé françois chérèque vous
protégez vous protéger et vous savez
c'est on est dans une société où on
aimerait bien que l'on dise un peu ce
que sa personnalité d'abord moi
j'entends dire que je suis très sérieux
mes collaborateurs et mes amis savent
parce que j'ai parce que je suis
j'exerce la responsabilité de 4 agira de
la cfdt puis dans le même temps j'ai une
vie qui m'est propre et que je protège
c'est vrai parce que je ne vois pas
l'intérêt d'abord ça d'intérêt pour
personne à part pour moi donc françois
chérèque jeudi passé le choc de la
première année vous avez - vous protéger
en seulement ce qui va se passer
nous y sommes au bout d'un an c'est
évident que mois après mois on est plus
à l'aise on se lâche
voilà moi j'ai aussi vérifier je vais
toutes les semaines dans des équipes
voir des équipes c'est l'été je vais
dans les entreprises
et je vois bien qu'il ya une proximité
qui est forte
j'adore cet exercice là d'ailleurs c'est
ce moment là donc peut-être que petit à
petit on s'extériorise un peu plus mais
ce qui concerne ma vie propre ça restera
ma vie propre en tout cas eu la chance
donnée par françois chérèque de faire
cette transition en douceur ce passage
de témoin
peu à peu à la tête de la cfdt ça c'est
une chance que vous avez donné françois
chérèque
oui c'est on a vécu une transition en
douceur et qui était à la fois
extrêmement sérieuse sur la transmission
des sujets des dossiers et on l'a et en
même temps extrêmement amicale
d'ailleurs on se voit régulièrement
parce qu'on est rendu compte d'un ami
non pas pour des conseils avant non pas
pour des conseils pour recevoir entre
copains voilà donc mais ceci étant dit
une fois qu'on voit effectivement
raconter vos premières négociations ce
qui s'est passé quand on arrive tout
d'un coup quand on se rend tout ça
travail mais la question de perrine c
est ce que vous a donné un peu les clés
d'une rencontre dans le tour du premier
ministre du chef de l'état mais il ya eu
tout un moment où on a fait les choses
à deux on a rencontré un certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs donc nous on a la
chance
sap a été donné à tout le monde d'avoir
vécu une transition extrêmement douceur
entre des personnes de personnes
extrêmement différente un françois est
un méridional moi je suis de l'ouest
c'est sans doute un peu plus tempérée
mai mais qui s'apprécient énormément bon
c'est une chance et je le remercie et
d'ailleurs nos biens sont extrêmement
forts autre petit nouveau autour de la
table des négociations sociales c'est
pierre gattaz le patron du medef alors
lui connaît des débuts un petit peu plus
difficile à la tête du patronat
puisqu'il est déjà contestée pour
certains de ces méthodes et de ses
déclarations
comment vous le percevez vous pierre
gattaz voile à bord c'est un homme
sincère je crois que c'est un chef
d'entreprise il sait de quoi il parle il
parle de l'entreprise il est cash donc
c'est pas pour me déplaire parce que si
je suis réservé je suis cash
mais après moi je pense qu'il faut il
faut il ya nécessité que le patronat est
donc que pierre gattaz redit ce que le
dialogue social est un facteur de
compétitivité de progrès et que ce soit
pas simplement je je je crains mais
c'est peut-être que ça va évoluer
je crois que il ya un espèce de réflexe
de se tourner vers le gouvernement en
disant voilà au je veux si je veux ça je
vais tel allègement mais qui n'oublie
que c'est le dialogue social qui pour un
certain nombre de sujets fait progresser
le pays aussi jusqu'au boutiste pour
l'instant
après une poussée il est on le fait tous
mais mais mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils redonnent un peu plus d'espacé
dialogue social est un jeu de rôle dans
la relation on est tous nos idées
non mais oui mais mais je crois que il
faut qu'on ait conscience en tout cas
moi c'est pour nous c'est pas une
posture que le dialogue social la
méthode d'élaboration des solutions est
extrêmement importante et que ça passe
par la confrontation des intérêts
divergents entre ceux du patronat et des
salariés mais pourrait faire faire
émerger des compromis ce qu'on a fait
sur l'accord emploi ce qu'on fait sur
d'autres sujets et ça il faut continuer
cette méthode là des opérations plus tôt
il est plutôt dans une espèce de tête à
tête avec le gouvernement essaie plutôt
problématique avec un risque de perte
d'influencé du coup du medef ah bah ça
c'est ça le regarde et là dessus oui
enfin moi moi je suis con si je
considère que dans une démocratie on a
besoin d'accords que les acteurs
s'organisant ensemble pour faire valoir
des intérêts qu'ils partagent
voilà je suis pas non plus faire
disparaître le patron là d'accord
d'accord peut-être vous intéressez vous
qui êtes historien de formation laurent
berger c'était une enquête de l institut
c'est ça qui est paru dans le quotidien
le monde de ce soir les français sont
très inquiets pour leur avenir et celui
de leur pays et ils ne se reconnaissent
aucune institution censés les
représenter que ce soit les politiques
les médias nous vous aussi les syndicats
est ce que selon vous on est donc dans
une société de déclin et de défiance
on n'est pas dans une société de déclare
il ya encore des choses qui fonctionnent
et à la formidable richesse dans ce pays
que ce soit des richesses individuelles
collectives les infrastructures non on
n'est pas dans le déclin
par contre dans une défiance forte on
attend une perte de confiance et il
appartient aux corps constitués comme on
dit aux médias mais aussi évidemment aux
politiques aux syndicalistes au patronat
de redonner des signes d'espoir de
redonner signe de mobilisation et je
crois que malheureusement trop souvent
il ya une espèce de repli sur soi de
crise de responsabilité comme j'ai nommé
qui fait que chacun a préfère regarder
ce qu'elle la responsabilité d'autres
que le sa propre responsabilité
c'est pas la posture de la cfdt c'est
moi qu'on puisse dire on a assumé un
certain nombre de responsables qui ont
des prêts à le faire mais il faut qu'il
y ait plus de monde autour de la table
mais on arrive donc à la fin d'un modèle
de société peut-être alors à moi je suis
persuadé qu'on a
faire des réformes moi je suis persuadé
qu'on est à la fin d'un modèle de
développement et qu'il ya une espèce de
peur parce qu'on sait pas vers quoi on
va donc il faut construire ce vers quoi
on va on peut faire mieux sans forcément
faire plus on peut réduire les
inégalités faire plus de qualité dans
l'emploi du travail et de la fabrication
des produits
voilà il faut qu'on avance vers ça il ya
la transition il est écologique qui ne
certaine manière est une opportunité
pour faire ça il faut qu'on la saisisse
et comme on donne pas à voir ce qu'est
après dans mon espèce il ya un espèce de
la croche chacun s'accroche ou modèles
d'avant qui est un peu dépassé voilà
c'est ça qui nous appartient de
construire
en tout cas on n'est pas dans un moment
très révolutionnaire comme le
sous-entend jean luc mélenchon il a dit
qu'on était en 1788
en tout cas on n'est point 10 788 je
confirme en 2013
ça c'est sûr et que ça n'a rien à voir
avec 10 788 par contre qu'on soit dans
un moment de malaise social important et
de malaise politique important c'est une
réalité
ce qu'il faut c'est en sortir et en
sortir c'est pas en faisant des discours
guerriers mais c'est en faisant en sorte
que l'intérêt général prime est dans
l'intérêt général c'est la réduction des
inégalités et c'est le fait que dans
notre société on laisse personne au bord
du chemin
alors là le classement pisa qui paraît
aujourd'hui sur le niveau scolaire des
élèves de 15 ans dans le cd va pas
tellement réconforter les français la
france qui a encore perdu deux places
comment vous réagissez
ce genre de classement je trouve ça un
peu effrayant pour être tout à fait
direct parce que on est dans un pays qui
a conscience des inégalités qu'il génère
dans son système éducatif mais qui est
dans une incapacité de le réformer
moi ce qui me frappe c'est qu'à la fin
de la maternelle quasiment on est
capable de dire qu'elles en feront leur
brevet leur bac on est incapable de
corriger cette prédiction pourquoi pas
parce que on est incapable de poser les
bonnes réformes en termes de programmes
en termes d'organisation de l'école je
pense notamment à la question des
rythmes
vous savez la question des rythmes on
nous serine entre guillemets avec les
périodes périscolaire c'est important
mais les rythmes c'est d'abord parce que
pour les élèves en difficulté on sait
que c'est physiologiquement beaucoup
plus intéressant en terme
d'apprentissage mais je ne trouve la
faisait pas le problème en terme
d'effectif donné du café fume pourtant
je pose
les effectifs sont considérées plus
risquées prieuré autonation par le jury
qui dépensent moins non sur les
effectifs globaux non mais sur les
priorités et l'affectation de ses
effectifs
oui je pense qu'il faut donner plus à
ceux comme moi il faut que je pense
qu'il faut donner plus de priorité aux
élèves qui ont mois et qu'on est dans
une logique élitiste on est dans un
système éducatif élitiste et je pense
qu'on fera monter tout ça on s'occupant
d'abord davantage de ceux qui sont le
plus en difficulté au fera monter
globalement tout le monde il ya quelques
jours alain juppé a réagi la
manifestation des professeurs des
classes préparatoires en dix ans on a
besoin d'une élite en france on sait que
vincent peillon et augmenter les
effectifs et les horaires des de ses
professeurs réduire leurs salaires et
les prix ce qui est prévu ça faudra pas
dire qu'on pourra pas construire une
élite
il faut quand même pas complète moi tout
confondre mais ceci étant vous savez il
ya deux jeunes illustrée avec un geste
ou soit vous faites monter en tirant
l'élite
et vous pensez que ça montera
directement par le bas ça ne marche plus
dans le système éducatif ça ne marche
plus soit vous considérez qu'il faut
prendre par le bas et vous faites monter
qu'il montre on pourra continuer de
construire l'élite et en même temps on
laissera personne au bord du chemin
je préfère cette société là qu'il faut
toucher aujourd'hui ou pas aux heures de
travail des professeurs en classe
préparatoire
je pense que vu les dangers espère
peut-être aussi ça franchement du
classement je pense que c'est pas le
sujet prioritaire en termes d'éducation
est le sujet prioritaire en termes
d'éducation ce sont les élèves en
difficulté derrière eux ce qu'on peut
demander alors tous les professeurs
cette fois peut travailler plus nicolas
sarkozy en avait eu une intention je me
souviens mais il travaille déjà les
professeurs mais plus mais mais mais
mais moi je trouve que c'est
voilà voilà la situation dans laquelle
on est il ya un problème de système
éducatif et on considère que c'est de la
faute des enseignants c'est parce qu'on
peut leur demander
on peut demander à la fin mais des
efforts ils en font énormément
on peut alors de on peut demander qu'à
un moment donné il ya des moyens qu'ils
soient alloués prioritairement aux
écoles en difficulté qu' il soit reconnu
que ce n'est pas exactement la même
chose d'exercer une classe d'avoir une
classe dans une banlieue difficile que
d'avoir une classe dans le 16e
arrondissement des tarifs technique pour
les établissements à ce moment-là
scolaire en tout cas peut-être des
moyens alloués prioritairement n'avait
plus besoin
très bien merci vous répondez toujours
attention ce n'est pas la faute
des chômeurs ce n'est pas la faute des
enseignants c'est pas forcément une
notion de faute qui accompagnent les
réformes n'auront c'est pas une question
de faute mais vous vous voyez qu'à un
moment donné on parle quand même de des
enseignants qui seraient responsables du
système éducatif qui va mal des chômeurs
qui sera responsable du chômage mais moi
je crois que dans ce pays il y à des
politiques il y a des pattes des
syndicalistes
il y à des patrons il y à des
associations qui exerce une
responsabilité
posons les choses sur la table faisons
les bons diagnostics écoutons les
citoyens les salariés prenons les
décisions prenons les décisions
voilà c'est le credo est la philosophie
de la cfdt que vous nous avez rappelé ce
soir laurent berger merci merci à vous
d'avoir été avec no mercy perrine
bonsoir à tous et à très vite
du coup